- This video was made
possible by Tab For A Cause.
Raise money for charity
just by opening tabs
which you were going to do
anyway, link in the description.
The Mueller Report is finally out,
and in it, Mr. Mueller
created a one-way street
that could not have found the
president committed a crime,
but it could have found him innocent.
And unless you understand
this legal framework,
you won't understand the
Mueller Report at all.
Hey Legal Eagles, today we are talking
about the Mueller Report.
I'm going to try to
explain the legal framework
that Mueller and his team created
and based their conclusions on,
because frankly, it colors
absolutely everything
in the report itself.
Mueller starts the report by setting
some legal ground rules.
This decision changes the course
of the entire investigation.
Mueller starts by noting that there is
an Office of Legal Counsel or OLC opinion,
and a DoJ policy not to
indict a sitting president.
In fact, I covered this
entire issue on a video
about whether a sitting
president can, in fact,
be indicted based on current
Supreme Court precedent,
which I'll link down below.
Mueller's view is not an unreasonable one.
This very issue has never been tested
by the Supreme Court,
and there are, in fact,
contrary OLC opinions and differing views
on the constitutional limits
of indicting a sitting president.
So, starting with the
premise that a president
cannot, in fact, be indicted
by the Department of Justice,
Mueller says that his hands are tied
because of quote fairness concerns.
Specifically, Mueller says that the power
of the government to accuse someone
of committing a crime has to be balanced
by constitutional protections, including
the right of the accused to a
quote neutral adjudicatory forum
so that the accused, if
they are in fact accused
of a crime by the government,
can clear their name.
Now, it is absolutely
100% true that things like
due process, a right to a
speedy trial, a right to a jury,
a right to face your accusers, it's all
incredibly important and enshrined
in the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights.
But because Mueller accepts
that he cannot indict
the president and put the
president through a formal trial,
the president would not
have those protections.
In other words, the
president would not be able
to potentially clear
his name through a trial
and the other mechanisms
that we normally give
to the accused.
So, given those two premises,
that because Mr. Mueller
cannot indict the president
and because the president
cannot clear his name,
that it would be wrong
to come to a formal conclusion
that the president broke the law.
Mueller notes that these
considerations disappear
when the president is not in office,
because when the president leaves office,
he is available to be accused and indicted
of any crimes that he may have committed.
In other words, Mueller
is leaving it to Congress
to impeach, for the president to resign,
or for the president
simply to leave office
for the normal mechanisms
of the judicial process to kick in.
On the other hand, because
the same fairness concerns
don't exist with respect to
finding someone innocent,
in other words, no one is
going to dispute the fact
that you have found them
innocent and try and
challenge that finding,
Mr. Mueller finds that
he can come to the conclusion
that the president was
innocent or that the evidence
did not amount to an indictable offense.
So based on the rules that Mueller set up,
there was no way that Mr.
Mueller could have found
President Trump committed any crime.
This is a standard that
does not exist anywhere else
in criminal law or, frankly, in politics.
Now, that's not to say
that this standard is wrong
or was improper, this is a
standard that may have to exist
based on the idiosyncrasies
of the Executive Branch
and the interplay between
the separation of powers
between the president and Congress.
But at the end of the
day, Mr. Mueller created
a one-way street.
The Mueller investigation could have
found the president innocent,
but it could not ever
have found him guilty.
As one of you Legal Eagles
pointed out on Twitter,
so in oversimplified terms,
they were allowed to rule
not guilty, or not not guilty,
and they ruled not not guilty.
And that's basically right.
Mueller states in the report that quote
"Based on the facts and the
applicable legal standards,
"we are unable to reach that judgment,"
that judgment being that
the president is innocent.
So, given this legal framework,
we might ask, what's the point
of the Mueller investigation.
Mueller decided to tie his
hands in the first instance.
I don't know if in fact this
is constitutionally mandated,
I don't think anyone does,
it's never been tested
in the Supreme Court, but
it's a very safe position.
It puts the ball in the court
of the political institutions,
namely Congress and the judiciary.
And it's hard to argue that in a world
where institutions are being eroded,
norms are being destroyed
and powers are simply
being claimed by various parts
of the government by fiat,
that this isn't a good
decision on a political level.
Mueller is clearly putting the ball
in the court of Congress, and by proxy,
the American people to make the decision
on this particular case.
On the other hand, a
lot of people are going
to look at this decision
and call it an abdication
of the power that was
specifically delegated
to the special counsel.
That we created these rules in the wake of
Watergate and eventually the
Clinton impeachment hearings
specifically to deal
with these types of cases
that are the hard cases.
And if it's not the special
prosecutor that's going
to deal with them, then who is?
These are difficult
questions and those are
reasonable positions
to take on both sides.
But according to Mr. Mueller himself,
because the investigation definitively
could not conclude that the
President of the United States
obstructed justice and colluded,
the purpose of the
investigation was to quote
"preserve the evidence
when memories were fresh
"and documentary
materials were available."
So effectively, Mueller
viewed his investigation
as one to gather the
evidence, to preserve it,
and to give it to the
powers that are going
to be responsible for
actually making a decision.
Now, I wanna be careful here, I don't view
the Mueller Report as
an impeachment referral
as some people have suggested.
Mr. Mueller clearly
contemplates, and even states,
that Congress has an oversight
role of the Executive.
And in fact, Mueller states that Congress
can punish the president for his actions.
That is in fact one of
its constitutional duties.
So for better or worse,
I think that we can view
Mr. Mueller as the
quintessential institutionalist
and we can view the Mueller Report
as the safest institutional play
that the special counsel
could have issued.
So given that this was an
evidence gathering mission,
let's examine the evidentiary findings.
In a prior video about the Barr Summary
of the Mueller Report, I
asked the question whether
this was a case where there
was, in fact, no evidence,
or whether this was a case where
there was a lot of evidence but not enough
to meet the beyond a
reasonable doubt standard.
Well, this report is worse than that.
With respect to collusion and conspiracy,
the Mueller Report finds
that there was actually
quite a lot of evidence,
including a string
of incredibly damning situations,
but looking at that
holistically wasn't enough
to be able to charge the
president with the crime
of conspiracy to collude with the Russians
as that is defined in the Mueller Report.
However, with respect to
obstruction of justice,
it's a whole different ballgame.
The Mueller Report finds numerous places
where Mr. Mueller
probably found obstruction
beyond a reasonable doubt, for example,
in one passage, Mueller says quote
"Our investigation found multiple acts
"by the President that were capable
"of exerting undue influence
over law enforcement
"investigations carried out
through one-on-one meetings
"in which he sought to
use his official power
"outside of his usual channels."
And in other places,
Mr. Mueller found quote
substantial evidence of
obstruction of justice.
And in one of the most damning passages,
Mr. Mueller states that
"The president's efforts to
influence the investigation
"were mostly unsuccessful,
but that is largely because
"the persons who surrounded the president
"declined to carry out his orders
"or accede to his requests."
It's hard to read these sections
and not come to the
conclusion that Mr. Mueller
thought President Trump
committed obstruction of justice
but only refrained from saying so
based on the legal
framework that he created
at the start of this investigation.
Because obstruction of justice includes
not only obstruction itself
but attempted obstruction,
in the same way that
firing a gun at someone
is attempted murder, even
if the bullet is defective
and doesn't, in fact, fire.
Mr. Mueller lays out 10
instances of possible
obstruction, analyzes
them, and mostly comes
to the conclusion that given those facts
and the relevant law that the situations
can give rise to obstruction of justice.
Here in this visual representation,
we can see one commentator color coded
all of the different
elements of obstruction
and compared that to the 10 instances of
potential obstruction by
the Trump administration.
And you can see that most
of the elements are met
for most of the potential instances.
But at the same time,
Mr. Mueller does not give
a standard by which we can
measure his conclusions.
For example, Mr. Mueller does not say
that we are certain
beyond a reasonable doubt
that this is an overt act as required
by obstruction of
justice or we are certain
beyond a reasonable
doubt that the president
had the corrupt motive required
for obstruction of justice.
But remember, based on
the rules that he created,
he could not come to that conclusion.
Instead, he leaves it
to Congress, and to us.
If this video leaves you wanting to make
some positive change in this
world, you're not alone.
I'd recommend Tab for a Cause,
which lets you raise money
for the charity of your choice
just by opening up new
tabs in your browser.
Tab for a Cause is a
Google Chrome extension
that allows you to pick a charity,
and then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of it being blank,
it displays a couple of ads
and the money you generate
is donated to your charity.
There is no charge to you, and it actually
does some good for this world.
Tab for a Cause users have raised
hundreds of thousands
of dollars for charity.
It is the easiest possible way
to do some good in this world.
So click on the link in the description
to download the extension,
and do some good
by doing what you were going to do anyway.
Surfing the internet.
Do you agree with Mr. Mueller's framework?
Do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
Real Law Reviews over here
where I talk about whether
a sitting president
can be indicted and a
bunch of other topics,
where I'll see you in court.